- Did you say, "Has it been a hard life?"
Oh, lord, yeah, it's been a hard life,
but I don't believe I'd
have it no other way.
- [Mark] All right, Markum Ray.
- [Markum] Yeah.
- [Mark] Markum Ray, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Markum] Right here in Manchester.
- [Mark] And you grew up
with both your parents?
- Well, yeah.
I grew up one of the poorest kids around.
- [Mark] One of the poorest?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
- Well, my childhood, I was stomped,
I was beat by a man that was one of
the best persons there ever was.
Other than that, it was more mental abuse
and physical abuse than
you'd know what to do with.
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff you go through?
- Well, your brains been split
out with everything you can,
stomped in the stomach,
whooped with cords,
switches and everything else.
- [Mark] This is your dad?
- Huh?
- This is your dad?
- Yeah.
And I've been on my own ever
since I was eight years old.
- Eight years old?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Why'd you leave at
eight, 'cause it was so rough?
- Just couldn't stand it no more.
- [Mark] And where'd you go at eight?
- I went to my grandmother's out here.
Stayed with her up 'til I
was about 20 and I left,
then I met a girl named Mary.
Married a girl named Mary
Harris, she was 15 years old.
We had two kids and in
1988 we got divorced,
and I still love her more today
than I did the first day we married.
- [Mark] Did you raise your kids?
- Well, I went, one of 'em,
her mother and dad raised
'cause we was too young,
you know what I'm saying?
But we couldn't get a
chance to raise a kid,
you know what I'm saying?
And then our baby boy, I went and got him.
My brother called me one
night and he told me,
he said, "Ray, if you don't
come and get this kid,"
said, "I'm gonna take
him to Social Services.
So I went the next day,
got him, brought him home.
I laid him down beside my mother.
He was here up 'til he got
with another women, with his woman.
- [Mark] What kind of jobs have you had?
- Tobacco work, roofing.
Lord, I couldn't tell ya all
what kind of, what I've had.
20-some years on the garbage route.
I've owned one home that was stolen
right out from under me
by a trailer company,
along with another friend of mine.
Their trailer was taken
right out from under them,
it never was even delivered.
They got their money.
And then there was a guy named.
My boy got sick one month
and I got behind on a trailer payment.
Guy told me, he said, "Ray,"
he said, "send me a double payment
first of the month,
everything will be fine."
I sent a double payment at the
first of the following month.
A week later I was called,
told me to get out of the trailer.
- [Mark] So you grew up here
in Manchester, Kentucky?
This is, you know, deep
in Appalachia, very poor.
- Right.
- [Mark] It's one of the
poorest parts of Kentucky, even.
- Exactly.
- [Mark] So that means it's the poorest
part of the country, probably.
What's it like growing up here?
You love Appalachia?
- I love Manchester more
than anything in the world.
It's just so hard here,
there's no work to do,
and I've been in and out of jail
more times than you
could count for drug use,
but I never was caught with no drugs,
and things like that.
There ain't no wonder there's so many
fighting, arguing, stealing
and all this stuff,
there's no work for people to do.
I mean, son, I know some of
the smartest people there are around,
smarter than college students.
Like these right down here at
this store right down here,
some of the best people you'll ever meet.
Some of the smartest people,
they're builders of everything,
and there's just no work
around here for 'em to do.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's the problem here.
It's so remote, so rural.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That there's,
there are no factories,
there's no jobs here, there's no nothing.
- There ain't nothing here.
- [Mark] What kind of
schooling did you get?
- Eighth grade.
- [Mark] Eighth grade.
- I dropped out when I was 15 years old.
- [Mark] But you can read and write?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what do you do for fun here?
What do you do for enjoyment?
- Well, I leave about
the crack of daylight,
after losing everything I had right there.
Almost $34,000 worth of stuff that,
like most people go to a furniture store
and pay two or $300 for,
I had to wind up paying for mine
by the month, 18, 24 months.
I had almost $34,000 worth of stuff
ruined right there in that
trailer, plus my home, too.
- [Mark] So that trailer's
empty and now you live in this?
- Well, no, it ain't empty,
it's got my things sitting in it,
but there's so many snakes
crawling around here
and things that it just,
I killed a copperhead crawling
right out of that wall the other day.
I stay on the road most of the time.
I come here at my mom's, I
lay down and I go to sleep.
I'm back up the next morning,
I'm on the road again.
I built my own bike, I
got a one-of-a-kind bike
and there ain't another
one on the road like it.
- [Mark] Where have you traveled?
You've been around the country?
- I've been to Detroit, Chicago, Georgia,
Ohio, Cincinnati, Hamilton.
Ain't too many places around
the Southeast I ain't been.
- [Mark] You ever think about leaving?
- Well, I've spent three-fourths
of my life on the road,
and I just grew tired of it.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- Huh?
- How old are you?
- 57.
And your health is good?
- Well, no, my health ain't that good.
I was diagnosed with cancer back about,
almost five years ago.
- [Mark] What kind of cancer?
- Brain cancer.
- [Mark] Brain cancer?
- Yeah.
You can't get no way around here
to get nowhere to go
nowhere or do nothing.
I was supposed to have went
to a cancer center, didn't go,
so I picked me up a Bible,
and I'm doing things now
that I never done before in my life.
I get out, I go places, things that I
used to love to do when I was growing up
that I don't even do anymore,
and, other than that-
- [Mark] So you didn't do chemotherapy
or anything like that?
- No.
- [Mark] How'd you treat it?
- With the Bible.
With the Bible and these two hands.
I've moved, let's see.
With just my cousin down there,
he had a place on his leg
which had moved right here.
I moved a place off his chest,
within 30 days it was gone.
Cousin had a blockage
right here, moved that.
It's just with these hands.
- [Mark] So drugs were a part
of your life at one point?
- Lord, yeah, I got hooked
up on, I got on some,
I always had bad headaches all my life,
and one day I was going
through Laurel County
and I was gonna stop
and get me some Tylenol
and a girl I was with, she said, "Here,"
she said, "here's something."
Said, "Take it," said, "it'll
take care of your headache."
Well, 30 days later (coughs)
after taking those two things,
I felt like I could walk on air.
From then on, that was from 1992 on up,
I was on drugs up 'til
about four years ago, bad.
Cocaine, pills, drinking,
which, I always smoked a little pot,
but, other than that, I tried meth twice,
I throwed it down, I said,
"No, I don't want none of that crap."
And only one thing I never
did do was get to the needle.
That's the God's honest truth.
- [Mark] So what were
you telling me earlier
about your family,
something that happened?
- [Markum] My granddaughter,
back when she was
about three years old, she was
brutally raped by somebody.
I don't know if they ever
did find out who done it,
and I said right then and there,
if I ever found out who
done that baby like that,
that they never would
do nobody else that way.
- [Mark] And they never caught the guy?
- [Markum] I never did
know if they did or not.
- [Mark] Is there a lot
of crazy behavior here?
- [Markum] Crazy (laughs).
Look at the side of that house right there
and you'll see what I (laughs).
See right there, them bullet holes?
- [Mark] Oh.
- It's where they mess around.
Every now and then you gotta look out,
see who's around your
house and everything.
Most people go to bed with,
they lock their doors and everything.
I sleep with mine open 'cause they know
I ain't gonna tolerate their bull crap.
I'm telling you God's honest truth.
One day my cousin came up missing,
and when they found him, he had been,
his throat had been cut, he
had been burnt, been strangled,
and my cousin, his daughter,
came out here that day
asking me would I help go find him
and I told her yeah.
My worst fears all my life came true
and we run up on her
dad back in that holler.
And that was the worst fear
I'd ever felt in my life.
I mean, it didn't exactly sink
in at the time I seen him.
I walked all the way around him.
I didn't get exactly what it
was, you know what I'm saying?
But when it did dawn on me,
I started doing pain pills,
and when I did it, I was running
up and down this road here,
70 and 80 miles an hour on a four-wheeler,
higher than a kite and
didn't even know it.
He's buried right up there.
They got the people that did it,
but every time I look
at that, to this day,
you know, I've forgot about a lot of it,
but to this day, it really gets to ya
seeing something like that.
I've seen more deaths up and
down this highway right yonder.
I've seen things you wouldn't believe
on that highway early of a morning.
A skeleton crossing the
road, caskets going across,
now, believe me, I'm telling
you the God's honest truth.
Some of the things that I've
seen, you wouldn't believe me.
That's the reason I kind of watch out
for Alyssa out through there of a night.
'Cause I've seen, you don't never know.
Little girl, her sleeping
in the room by herself.
You don't know who's
gonna be messing around.
You'd be surprised, some
of the people I've caught
right out there in that curve,
right behind Ella Mae's trailer,
and they didn't know I
was within a mile of 'em.
Of a night, I get out and I walk around
'cause I can't hardly, where I smoke,
I can't hardly breathe,
and I'm about to lay that down.
- [Mark] You have good friends?
- Huh?
- You have friends?
- Very few anymore.
But other than that, nah, I
don't deal with 'em, though.
I don't hardly deal with nobody no more.
I keep right to myself.
- [Mark] What about your family?
You see your mom, right?
- I'm not too close with my
family, that's the truth.
But now I've got a lot of friends
down the road, don't get me wrong.
I'm distancing myself from my old friends,
and I set myself on course
and I made myself a bunch of new friends.
- [Mark] Are you happy?
- Yeah, I'm the happiest
I've been in a long time.
I sit around and think about
the things I used to do
and I laugh, you wouldn't believe,
and some of the people I
meet, I get so tickled,
I swear, tears roll right down my eyes.
I'm telling you the God's honest truth.
- [Mark] Do you feel like you've lived
the life that you wanted to?
- Well, the way I see it, I've lived,
I've lived and done about most things
that only most men around this area
could even dream about.
The way I see it, have I
lived my life to the fullest?
No, I don't think I have yet.
- [Mark] And you're happy living here?
- Not here, I'm not.
- [Mark] But this part of the country?
- Yeah, this part of the county,
but I'm just not happy
in Curry Branch anymore.
For one thing, there's too much damage.
These homes have been
destroyed right here,
you can't get no help to do nothing.
- [Mark] Yeah, a lot
of 'em are just shacks.
- Huh?
- [Mark] A lot of 'em
are just, they look like-
- They're just flat-out wiped out.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I spent over $3,200 right
there inside that trailer.
Ran out of funds,
just lost it all.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned in life?
- Never trust nobody, except yourself.
Always watch, always listen
and learn to who's talking around you,
and most of all, if a woman
goes out on you one time,
get rid of her the next day,
'cause she will do it agan every time.
- [Mark] All right, Markum Ray,
thank you so much of talking with me, man.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] So glad we met.
- Appreciate it.
- [Mark] Thank you, man.